[Music]
Mandy Moore teases this is us season
three yeah we're the time go back I feel
like it's our best season yet I mean the
first we have the first three scripts
we're in the middle of Episode two right
now they're just it's such a fun time
because I it's kind of been on the
record that like our storylines like for
a Jack and Rebecca at least one of them
we're really exploring heavily this
season is when they first meet and it's
so much more fun to be happy and in 70s
like hair and makeup like all of that
combined and like young love is so much
more fun to portray than like this sort
of heaviness in the dark cloud that sort
of hungover season do so in that sense
it's like I feel like it's some of our
best best stuff yet most importantly
many more is back in the music studio
yeah I'm writing I just like I think
I've been inspired from the music that I
get to sing on the show but also like I
my fiance's a musician there's
constantly like there's music in our
lives every single day he's always
writing we started writing together not
so long ago and something just flipped
in me like I can't wait for somebody
else to like tell me hey we're waiting
on music for you like had just sort of
beat it had to come from me so in that
sense I'm like really I'm psyched about
it do you guys think there could be like
a duet album or do you think this will
be a new album from you it would be a
record of my own I don't know if it will
necessarily be like a full like LP a
full album maybe it'll just be an EP I'm
not putting my I'm not really putting a
ton of pressure on myself right now to
figure out what it it's gonna be but I'm
just making music et spoke with Mandy at
the premiere of her new sci-fi film the
darkest minds Ruby you are very rare
among the most powerful more that I try
to control it
the more damage that they do based on
the movie what is one thing you once
thought of maybe as a personal flaw that
turned out to be a strength for you my
sensitivity I feel like I can be
sometimes overly sensitive but as I've
gotten older I've learned to use it to
my advantage and it's something that I
actually have to call on for my job
quite often to like to be able to tap
into that sentimentality and that like
deep emotional well it's right there
you